سوريا مختبر دولي للطائرات المسيره هكذا
وصفتها منظمه باكس الهولنديه لبناء السلام
قائله ان كل من الولايات المتحده وروسيا
وايران واسرائيل وتركيا فضلا عن قوات
النظام استخدمت 39 نوعا مختلفا من
المسيارات خلال النزاع المستمر منذ العام
2011 وفق وفوق بيوت السوريين ورؤسهم
اختبارات وطورت هذه الدول انواع الجديده
من المسيارات ودرست كيف يمكن لاستخدامها
ان يحسنه من التكتكات والاستراتيجيات
العسكريه في شمال سوريا تعول القوات
التركيه بشكل كبير على الطائرات المسيره
التي لعبت دورا في عمليتها العسكريه التي
شنتها منذ العام 2016 وتمكنت من خلالها من
السيطره على مناطق حدودها كذلك اثبتت
الحرب انها افضل مختبر للطائرات من دون
طيار الروسيه وقد سمحت لموسكو ان تقيما
مسيرات حلفائها وان تختبر مسيرات مقاتله
واسلحتها وفقت تقرير الذي اشار الى دور
مهم لعبته المسيرات الروسيه في تغيير مسار
الحرب لصالح قوات النظام السوري ايران
ايضا زودت ميليشيتها في سوريا بمسيرات
استخداماتها ضد السوريين لصالح النظافه
[موسيقى]